okay uh welcome to the last day or half
day um
we'll begin with uh singh who will tell
us about computationally tractable near
optimal design of experiments she does
machine learning statistics and
uh good morning everyone and uh thanks
to the organizers for the invitation
so uh let me start by uh before i focus
on the design of experiments sort of the
higher level picture which i guess uh
aligns well with uh some of the
discussion that was happening last night
evening at the panel
which is this idea about big data but
small labels
right so we've all been really excited
about that
you know i went in like collecting lots
and lots of data there were lots of
initiatives that were started on big
data but really the bottleneck
comes down to that you can have i mean
if you think about imagenet and so on
lots of images but ultimately somebody
has to sit down and label them right so
you need to do like some mechanical talk
experiment or in some cases the labels
are actually the outcome of very
expensive experiments so it's just not
feasible to collect all the data and
people have been trying to address this
challenge in various ways i'll just list
some of the attempts here
but there are many many more so semi
supervised learning is the setting where
you say you have a lot of unlabeled data
and some random subset of it is labeled
so how can we learn from that by taking
advantage of the unlabeled data as well
in addition to the label data
experimental design which is what i'll
focus on is about now choosing which
given a pool of unlabeled data which
ones you want to get labels for okay so
it's about doing a selection but doing
the selection a priori before you
collect any of the labels
okay and that's what distinguishes it at
least in my definition from active
learning where in active learning you
can
take look at your unlabeled pool collect
some of the labels and based on that
feedback you gain you can decide where
to sample next which labels to collect
next so that feedback driven
experimental design if you want to call
it is what is active learning so this
would be non-feedback driven and this
would be feedback driven and there are
other settings like transfer learning
where you might think that there is one
domain in which you have a lot of label
data and another domain where you have
little label data so how can you uh
transfer the information learned in one
domain to another
and again uh these are this is only a
sampling there are many more attempts at
trying to address this big data but
small label kind of setting and i've
worked on
at least the ones listed here uh today
i'll focus on experimental design but
let me say that i think all of these
are uh
in some sense there's a lot of need to
do statistical grounding work for these
label efficient methods there has been i
mean uh progress made but um like what
came up in the discussion yesterday like
how do you come up with confidence
intervals for these settings where your
sampling strategies are very complex
they are feedback driven
some of those are really uh open
questions and what i'll talk about today
is actually not not trying to address
those but just a step back and just
saying how can we make experimental
design more computationally tractable
okay so for the rest of the talk i'll
focus on experimental design but just uh
it falls under this sort of bigger
umbrella of thinking of what if we have
small labels where should we be
collecting them where should we be
spending our effort
on uh the label collection
all right so the problem comes up in
many many scenarios uh we can have
profiles of lots of buildings but if
you're trying to predict the energy
usage of a building then you need to go
and collect their uh you know
electricity usage records and so on or
their bills utility bills and that's
expensive so you can only hope to do it
from like some of the
for some few buildings that might be
available and you need to decide which
ones which buildings are sort of most
representative that you might want to go
and collect these uh bills for similarly
healthcare records you can have lots of
healthcare records of how different
patients were treated but then if you
want to get patient satisfaction
uh surveys then you have to again do
some kind of sampling or survey to
decide these
and the last two are somewhat closer to
my heart in the sense that these are
scientific applications and i
collaborate with people
where it's really a problem because
every label is really expensive so one
is just a very simple problem where they
put people in a fmri scanner and anybody
who's been in an fmrs scanner knows how
painful it is in some sense so you can't
if you're trying to understand say the
visual system of the human brain by
looking at how the brain responds to
images
then you can't hope to show them all
possible images and request look at the
response you have to be selective about
which images do i choose to show to a
person in a scanner all right
so again you can think of this as
external design is one way of course you
can also use feedback if you can do it
in real time decide which images to show
next based on the previous ones uh but
i'm just using it here as a motivation
another one on which actually i'll show
some result is uh material synthesis so
again people are and i think the song
also talked about a similar application
yesterday
my setting is a bit simpler we're trying
to synthesize materials with desired
properties
there are a lot of experimental settings
you can try but of course every
experiment here requires you know it's a
bit lab experiment like they go in the
lab they're trying to like you know
synthesize materials under different
conditions different uh temperature
pressure uh whole time runtime there are
like lots of how much concentration of
solutions is involved
like there are a lot of settings like
that and which settings do we actually
try out in the lab to be able to predict
the properties of a material we might
synthesize under another set of
experiments efficiently okay so i think
yeah everybody gets the idea
so the larger question is given a large
pool of data with a label budget how to
sub sample the data points for labeling
and again this would be an experimental
design which is like the non-feedback
driven setting you're just given a pool
which one should i label
okay and in fact we'll do this under a
very simple model where turns out even
here there are challenges so this very
simple model is just that i believe my
labels are generated according to a
stochastic model which is just a linear
model it's x which is your
fixed data matrix or set of experiments
so n is it's a tall matrix n number of
experiments that you can potentially
conduct p is some descriptors of those
settings for example it could be the
different
external parameters you are varying
temperature pressure and so on
um and there are the corresponding
regression coefficients and we believe
that our label is just generated as a
linear combination of these plus some
it's a very simple noise just iid
gaussian zero mean noise
okay so a very simple model
and uh let me emphasize again we are
thinking of the large sample setting
where you have a lot of parameter
settings to try out so n is much larger
than p so it's a tall matrix x
okay
and we'll be interested in two
goals and actually later on i'll
generalize it to some other goals as
well but one of those is estimation can
we estimate the true regression
coefficient vector beta because that
will tell me something about how
important how relevant each of the
parameters is in my design so we want to
be able to re
reconstruct beta well and another is
prediction which means that i want to be
able to predict the label of a
potentially different data z
all right so that means we are the label
there would be or
a predicted level would be z beta
all right
and uh the question we are asking is
what if i can only collect k out of the
n labels
so you can potentially have all the n
labels here generated according to this
model but i'm telling you you can't
measure or collect all wise you're only
limited to k out of the n
so it's a subset selection problem
and
as we'll see it has some of the same
challenges as come up in other subset
selection problems as well
right so uh typically k
is of course less than n
right because you're doing a selection
but it also makes sense to talk about k
bigger than p because p is the number of
parameters so you need at least as many
samples if your goal is for example to
estimate the true regression coefficient
vector beta
all right
so hopefully the setup is clear
all right so let's first talk about what
happens if we do have all the labels or
all the n for all the n data points then
uh we can do simply what's called the
least square solution right so we can
look at the ordinary least squares in
fact it's known to be minimax optimal or
in many ways optimal
and the solution is just given as
follows it's just x transpose x inverse
x transpose y where here we are saying y
is the set of labels for all the data
points assuming those are given to us
and if we look at what's the estimation
error and the prediction error of this
particular estimate the ols estimate
then it's given as follows it's sigma
square which is the noise variance times
trace of x transpose x inverse and uh
the prediction error is correspondingly
given as z transpose z times x transpose
x inverse
all right so this is what's possible
with fully labeled
data
and sure
estimation error uh well okay it is
decaying in the sense that uh
or maybe i'm missing one by n there yes
you're right so it should be okay
it should be this should be the
covariance of these points so you will
get a if if it's identity this will be p
and you'll get a p over n so you're
right yeah maybe i'm missing a divided
by n there right
yeah i think initially i'd return it in
terms of sigma but then sample
covariance but yeah if you write x
transpose x i guess the n needs to be
there because then it'll be sigma square
p over n thanks
okay so what we care about is the
minimax optimal uh solution so here i
define minimax optimality as
uh the expected value of the risk the
risk being either the squared error
difference for estimating beta or for
the prediction
and i'm taking sub over
all uh betas which are p dimensional and
the if is over all algorithms and by an
algorithm we mean both away an estimator
that will take whatever data is given to
you and estimate beta from it and also a
sampling strategy that decides which
labels to query okay so the sampling
strategy plus estimator that's what will
be an algorithm and the sampling
strategy could be deterministic or it
could be random sampling with or without
replacement and we'll look at examples
of all of these
and the goal is to uh basically say how
far are we from the this minimax optimal
solution
all right so of course this is a very
classical problem in statistics this has
been addressed for uh you know long long
ago and uh there are solutions which are
known they are known as uh for at least
these two objectives that i mentioned
the estimation and the prediction
objective it's known as the a optimality
which is you basically look at what the
ols solution error is and you say let me
just try to find the subset which
minimizes
this error over all possible choices
of sub samples s which are of size no
more than k right so k is my budget on
how many levels can be collected i look
for the set of rows s
which is carnality no more than k that
minimizes this loss
all right and you can define the same
for v optimality the other one for
prediction
right so it's nice i mean classical
statistics show this is the optimal
solutions so why are we revisiting the
problem
if you think about it uh this involves
a minimization over all possible subsets
right so it's clearly oh there was a
question yeah question of nomenclature
sure this this part somehow i missed i
don't know why this is called a and b
optimum
uh
it turns out this one is addressing the
i mean what does the a stand for
b stands for variance a stands for i
don't remember um
but
it's classical statistics i just took
whatever they call it i've also always
seen this you know nomenclature but just
right now the first time i wondered why
is it called a oxygen or maybe even i
don't remember v i think is for variance
optimal so this is optimizing the
variance of your solution and they also
have other letters of the yes so i will
mention some of the other ones d e t g
and so on
but to keep things simple here actually
let's say we'll mostly focus on a i'll
just mention some results for v and then
the latest set of results we have also
applied to other criteria as well
yeah i don't remember what that yeah why
the letters come from uh for wheat's
variants
all right
okay so yeah before i mention the
challenge here let me just say well what
do you do once you compute these um you
know the classical statistical solutions
is that now you can just do ols on the
sub sample data points and that's again
optimal
right
so the challenge here is that uh of
course we are searching for all possible
subsets of size k out of the n and so
it's a combinatorial solution which has
complexity n to the k you're doing n
choose k
right um
yeah doing the minimization over n
choose k possibilities
so we'd like to do this in a
computationally tractable manner
so of course there's been related work
but uh
i'll mention the related work but let me
also mention a lot there's a lot of work
that's relevant but a lot of it focuses
on sub sampling for linear regression
but it focuses on trying to approximate
the full sample ols solution
okay so by full sample oles it means
that if you had access to all the y
labels you were able to do the
uh compute the beta ols then it's
talking about how far is my subsample
solution from that and my goal in terms
of minimaxity is how far are you from
the best k subset that you can choose
and these are different goals what i
mentioned in graded work because of
course these results which actually
focus on the computational aspects to
say can we compute the ols solution but
in a faster way they are not really
measurement constraint but they are just
saying can i compute the solution faster
so those they also have some
implications for our setting but but
just the focus is different okay their
focus is computational our focus is
measurement constraint budget
constraints
okay so here's an algorithm a recent one
by avron and buddhist
where they proposed a polynomial time
deterministic algorithm that selects
k
rows from this from a given an x matrix
k bigger than p
such that the following guarantee holds
okay so uh here the dagger represents
the pseudo inverse and at first glance
this is a different objective but it's
easy to rewrite it and you'll see that
it's actually the same as the a
optimality objective i mentioned earlier
where x dagger for venus term square is
just the trace of x transpose x inverse
so what this result tells us is that
they can find a subset
which is
essentially like an n by k approximation
of the full sample solution
so again here the focus was how do we
just compute it faster
and
uh the full label solution and so you
can have this approximation
and the
algorithm is actually it's pretty nice
in fact we'll reuse it but on a
different set of data points
okay so the algorithm is as follows
here's a serial code it's a greedy
removal of the rows you start with all
your rows in your x matrix
and um for n minus k iterations you
compute the svd of the current uh set of
rows that you have and you choose one
row based on its importance which is
given by uh looking at eigen
decomposition and the relevance
relevance of each row according to that
okay and then you just remove that row
and you keep repeating this procedure so
it's a very greedy removal of the rose
okay
and uh of course you can just translate
that result to the following result on
the
estimation error in uh recovering the
two beta which is n by k times sigma
square trace x transpose x inverse
okay so and assuming k is bigger than 2p
right because here we had some k minus p
so as long as k is bigger than 2p you
get the n by k approximation so it is an
n by k approximation factor for
approximating the full label ols
but again our question is can it be
improved for prof approximating the best
k-label ols
okay so if i could search for the best
possible
set of samples to label then i'm
comparing against that and not against
the full solution
okay because we're in this budgeted
setting
let me mention another related work so
leverage score sampling is also very
popular and it has been used for
approximating generating a low rank
approximation of a matrix it's also been
used for speeding up
linear regression again focusing on the
computational aspect and it also has
nice guarantees in terms of the full
sample solution
but recently uh here at berkeley mike
mahoney who has worked a lot on lever
score sampling and uh ben you who's a
statistician they put their heads
together and said well what if we
analyze this
under a stochastic model where you
believe that it's coming from a linear
model with some iod gaussian noise let's
see uh how well does do leverage scores
do so leverage score of a data point is
just given here
it's x i transpose x transpose x inverse
x i it's again a measure of the
importance of every row or column uh
it's essentially like looking at the
projection of each row or column onto
the top k
uh subspace and look looking at what's
that projection look like how large is
it and so the leverage score sampling is
you just sample proportional to the
leverage course
and uh you actually do in a weighted olf
solution so you basically sample your
rows according to the leverage score and
then you re-weight them
and solve the least squares problem
and this is uh has nice properties as i
said in terms of approximating the full
ols in fact what we know is that
leveraged score sampling is good for the
full sample ols under a worst case model
or a non-stochastic model where we are
not assuming this nice gaussian noise
but it turns out what they show is that
leverage score sampling can actually be
worse than uniform sampling for
estimating the regression coefficients
in a stochastic model
okay
and they in fact propose some solution
but don't give an analysis for this
setting so this is rigorously
established in their paper uh exactly
when uniform sampling works better than
uh leveraged score sampling but their uh
fixes don't have analysis so they
propose either using a mixture of
uniform leverage score sampling or using
leveraged score sampling with the
different with just the ols not the
weighted wireless
solution but um yeah
there aren't any guarantees for that one
so we'll also compare against leveraged
score sampling just because it is a nice
idea in general
so let's get back to the classical
experimental design and see what we can
do to the these ah solutions to make
them computationally tractable
tractable
okay so what we do is a simple convex
relaxation
okay so the way i would think of this is
imagine that i have my x transpose x i'm
basically putting a big matrix in
between that's a binary matrix it's a
diagonal matrix with a one on the
diagonal if i'm picking that
uh row or if you're allowing uh with
replacement sampling then it could be up
to k you could pick one thing k times
but the total number of ones along the
diagonal have to sum to k
right and so what we do here is a convex
relaxation of that we say that we'll
have this big diagonal matrix in between
but its entries on the diagonal have to
be bounded between zero and one
okay so uh we are relaxing it not to be
integers
and uh we still require them to sum to k
right so the sum of all the entries on
the diagonal should be less than k
and it turns out actually this uh the
reason i have this in a
this different box is because you only
require this upper constraint if you are
doing without replacement sampling for
with replacement you can actually drop
this constraint
basically another way to think of this
is you can think of pi i divided by k as
the probability of sampling a row and so
bounding this ensures that in k rounds
if i think of pi over k as my sampling
probability then it's limiting that you
want in k draws
you right the upper bound on
this ensures that you the data point i
is not sampled more than once in k draws
so this part i mean it doesn't change
the optimization too much but it's only
needed for without replacement sampling
okay so this is a nice convex relaxation
uh what can we say about it how far is
it from the true solution
so first let me show you a lower bound
which is sort of intuitive but it turns
out there's a little bit of work to
actually argue that the lower bone
applies so you'll think well it's just a
convex relaxation it should be a lower
bound for my true problem that's true
but showing that it's a lower bound for
the minimax problem
is slightly more involved because you're
talking about what kind of algorithms
you can allow here can they do so with
replacement sampling or without
replacement sampling but up to that you
can show that this convex relaxation
objective lower bounds your minimax
error for both estimation and prediction
okay and of course what we'll like to
know is what's the upper bound
okay do we have a matching uh or at
least pretty close upper bound as well
or not okay so let me mention that there
are two actually challenges here one is
that
if you just look at this objective it
only returns the sampling probability if
you want to think of it as pi star
actually pi star over k is the sampling
probability but think of it as a
sampling probability so it doesn't
really give us a subset directly right
so we need to take this pi star and we
need to figure out a way to select the
k or approximately k depending on
whether we have a hard size constraint
or soft size constraint number of sub
samples from this that's one challenge
and the second challenge is even though
i told you well this is a convex
relaxation it is a convex program you
can verify that but
if you try to solve it right away it
seems like it can be cast as a semi
definite program and you can solve it
which is convex but we know stps are not
really good right they only scale to
problems of size 200 or 300 it's hard to
make them work for lots uh
settings so i'll present one approach we
have in terms of not using stps but a
projective gradient descent to solve it
but i'll also mention some interesting i
think open directions there i think that
those results can be strengthened
further
but first let me focus on the first
question which is how can we take the
solution of this program this pi star
and get a subset of rows or columns from
it or rows up from it sorry
so the first thing we tried was let's
just use it as a probability
distribution and sample according to it
okay
so we'll do both sample without
replacement and with replacement and the
strategies are with replay without
replacement is actually easy so if we
have a soft budget by that what i mean
is that the number of uh
subsets or rows we are allowed to pick
is
order k with high probability okay
then uh what we do is we just for every
row we just toss a coin with the
probability uh related by a star and we
uh decide to sample that row or
otherwise not selected
and if we have a hard budget constraint
we do the same but um we uh actually
pick a row at random from unselected
pool we don't toss independent coins we
first start by picking one of the rules
uh rows selecting it according to
bernoulli pro probability pi star i and
then we basically stop whenever we have
k okay
so some slight difference for soft
budget versus hard budget but
it's a fairly easy sampling
solution
sample with replacement is slightly more
involved but
basically what you do is you again in
the soft widget setting you sample a row
according to pi star and then you repeat
it certain number of times right because
it's with replacement you're allowed to
repeat rows so here we repeat it
basically p over k
and this thing in the denominator can be
thought of as the leverage score of the
condition matrix
where we have used the pi star
so this is like the covariance matrix
but it's of the condition uh it has the
direct pi star already in there so think
of you have already uh rescaled your x
and then you're computing the leverage
course of that yes
i is just the row that you're sampling
so for the i throw you sample a row if
you sampled i th or row you repeated
this many times
all right
and uh in the heart budget you just you
basically since here you are doing it in
a sampling one row at a time you just
stop when you have cake
all right the sampling strategy
clear okay so what can we show about
this so here's the result we have
it says that
for with replacement provided we have
some condition which relates p which is
the number of
variables in our problem k which is our
budget and epsilon which is the
guarantee we will have
and if uh if so another way to think of
it is the budget k as long as it's like
p
over epsilon square right uh for with
replacement then we have that uh the
number of
rows that are sampled are opk with high
probability using the soft budget and
the ols estimator on the selected point
satisfies a one plus epsilon
approximation to the
minimax i mean to the um
sorry the
convex solution right so one plus
epsilon
uh now we have an estimator right so
earlier we had shown a lower bound on
the minimax error in terms of f opt the
solution of our convex optimization now
i have an upper bound which is a one
plus epsilon close
to uh write the best solution
and there's a slightly different
requirement for with replacement and you
see this one has some condition number
of this
sigma star this condition covariance
coming in
which is undesirable we don't know how
to get rid of it right now but let me
just make some comments that the key
needed even in this case is not too
large because this is not the
conditioning of the original
some data points that are given to you
this is a conditioning of the sort of
sigma star which is you have already
you know uh scaled some of your rows and
columns so it's supposed to be better
you can in fact show that it is better
than the original uh data matrix so it's
expected to be not too large and another
thing is this f of t and g out these um
solutions to the convex program they
since they are just a context relaxation
of the combinatorial objectives so we
also get a one plus epsilon
approximation to the combinatorial a and
b optimal solutions
right because i can just upper bound f
opt by the a optimality solution and g
out by the
uh or by the v optimality solution
okay
so uh this is nice let me uh give you
just a very high level this is really
very high level sketch of the proof idea
so the idea is that once we have uh
we've chosen the subset right we are
just doing ols on it so we can write its
error as just sigma square trace x
transpose x right of for the points that
we have chosen is inverse
so that's uh straightforward now there's
literally only one step that we need
which is
if we can show that this trace
is
bounded by one plus epsilon times the
trace of this condition thing
that is precisely our
convex solution
okay so this is the only step we need to
show and if we can show that we have a
one plus epsilon approximation
now the key thing to realize is we are
basically talking about the trace of the
inverse of a matrix so it's just the sum
of the inverse of the eigenvalues of
the matrix right so as long as we can
show that all the eigen values at this
is one approach all the eigen values are
within one plus minus epsilon of each
other for the two matrices under
consideration then we'll have one plus
epsilon approximation
and to show that we actually leverage
some results from the classical work of
spielmann and chobasawa
but this was for effective resistance
sampling or graph sub sampling its
specification there are many ways it's
known by right so the argument is
inspired by that but essentially we show
that this
sub-sampled
matrix that we have chosen is a good
spectral approximation of this
condition covariance
and once you show that then the argument
follows
and in fact let me make one more remark
so any improvements in this result or in
graph specification directly imply an
improvement for our setting as well but
let me mention that our problem is
slightly different in that we since we
only care about an upper bound on this
right so it suffices to just come up
with a one-sided right we don't need
both sides of the spectral specification
we as long as the smallest eigenvalue
right we can show is preserved
uh that's enough
so we only need a one-sided unweighted
sparsifier for a weighted graph so the
weighted graph been given by pi star and
this you can think of it as an
unweighted sparsifier because we are
just deciding whether to keep a sample
or not
so any results if you know of better
results for that well we have used some
better results but
if you know our further ones will
directly lead to an improvement here
okay so let me summarize the results for
sampling according to pi star this
convex solution
so uh
yeah here are the results i talked about
that we can get one plus epsilon
approximation under a soft budget with p
log
k over k scaling like epsilon square you
can also translate it into a hard budget
s equal to k right if you can't if you
are only allowed that you can only pick
k experiments you can't pick order k
right then we can get a order one
approximation so in that case the
results are slightly worse
so what we would like to next ask is can
we get a relative one plus epsilon error
approximation with the hard budget
because ideally you would like to
minimize the number of experiments to as
small as possible
right so you some you may not be allowed
over sampling
uh which happens in most practical
scenarios so can we get that
yeah
in terms of the first line is is it sort
of clear that
we that we would need
p over epsilon squared no it's not so
yeah so the ideal goal which i'll
mention in a minute i think is
whether it's achievable or not i don't
know what would be p over epsilon right
and in fact this one also has a log b so
i'll mention some results where we are
able to get p over epsilon square or p
square over epsilon we can't get p over
epsilon that's the open question
okay so i'll talk about that yeah
all right so yeah what do we do uh so we
try to first see well with hard budget
can we get a one plus epsilon
approximation
and one idea was that because if you
look at our object this combinatorial uh
optimization problem and how we relax it
essentially we are doing this like sort
of l1 relaxation of l naught constraint
on the
pi stars right so one of our solution is
that it already sparse
so can we analyze pi star and look at
its support
and if we can argue that's you know
k or order k then we are probably we can
just stop there we don't need the
sampling step
so we looked at it and in theory we can
show so this requires a very mild
condition that the
points are in general position
but if you assume that we can show that
it's k plus p square is what the support
looks like
and in simulations though um
it seems like it actually is sort of
linear it should be k plus p
okay but we can't tighten the theory uh
to get that
uh but yeah at least even with k plus p
square if you want to get a hard budget
constraint here's one idea that instead
of sampling data points according to pi
star we can just start from the support
of pi star and we can really remove some
so what we do here is basically apply
everyone batista's idea of greedy
removal of the rose to the support of pi
star so it's a greedy post processing so
what we are giving as input to their
algorithm is now not all the points but
whatever is the support of our convex
taxation solution
okay
and you keep basically removing a row
uh that has uh that minimizes our
objective essentially
greedy you just remove those and uh
that's your
result
and so with this greedy algorithm what
we can show is
it's actually also well at least if p is
small it's faster to run if p is much
smaller than n
it gets the one plus epsilon
approximation with a hard budget
constraint
but the budget constraint scales like p
square over epsilon now so notice that
if i compare it to this here we have p
scaling or k scaling like
p log p over epsilon square
right so uh
yeah now instead of k scaling like p we
have k scaling like p square at least
that's one difference
right but it does allow us to get a one
plus epsilon approximation with a hard
widget
that's great
so um
let me mention one other um
solution we have uh without going into
the detail so i thought i'll mention
that result and we can revisit it if i
have time later on i'll tell you what
the result is without telling you the
method but we can discuss the method
five time okay so the question is here
can we improve this budget further and
bring it down to p
so that our budget only needs to scale
with the number of parameters which is
what we should hope for right
okay so here's um
this is a new set of results we have and
these are really inspired by recent work
on graph specifications
these two papers um and in fact zion
alan zhu he's one of our co-authors on
this one because we can use ideas from
their uh result on uh graph
specification they basically show that
you can pose this problem of minimum
eigenvalue as a regret minimization and
i can go over the details later if i
have time but uh we can use their regard
minimization framework and uh do that
without and with replacement and now we
can actually also these this is where
you see all the other letters we talked
about so it can actually handle even
other criteria not just the a and the v
optimality but a v there's a d
optimality which tries to maximize the
volume of these subsample points e t and
g and it can work for all of those
and has a run time given here at least
it's still linear with n and it gets a
one plus epsilon approximation and there
are many results we have for different
settings so without replacement uh for
the first two with replacement for the
last one the requirements are uh like we
could push k almost all the way down to
2p but you are stuck with order one
approximation we can get one plus
epsilon in these two cases here our k is
actually linear in p
right but the
epsilon square dependence is still
epsilon square whereas the greedy one
has epsilon
so
we have improved the budget in terms of
getting it to scale with the number of
parameters p but it's still i think an
open question on can we get uh p over
epsilon
relative error approximation
right and i guess this
ah
there's some indication that
that may not be possible with a hard
budget you might need to do a little bit
of over sampling
uh to get to be over epsilon but closing
this gap is still
open
so if you have time i'll get back to
what the regret minimization idea is but
let me also switch to how we would
actually solve it because i'm sure i
mean i know some of you are working on
optimization maybe you have ideas about
how to make that aspect faster
so as i said this is a convex relaxation
right and ah and i've already talked
about so whenever i wrote the runtime
here the t opt was the runtime of that
convex solution to get by star and then
whatever i've written next is just the
complexity of how do you take pi star
and then post process it right using sub
sampling or greedy removal or regret
minimization to get a subset so those
complexities are linear in n the
question is how does the
runtime of the
convex optimization scale this specific
convex optimization and as i said this
can be written as a semi-definite
program which is nice but we would like
to come up with a solution that's faster
and can scale to problems of larger size
so what we did was we actually
implemented it using a projective
gradient descent algorithm which is
fairly straightforward so you start with
you have your objective function either
a optimality or the v optimal one the
convex
convex
relaxation of it you have your feasible
solution set right
and uh you initialize uniformly
essentially so you're sampling every row
with same probability
there are some parameters that will show
up but the algorithm is not too
sensitive to those in fact we just used
some standard settings and we tried
wearing those it wasn't too sensitive
so the algorithm is just what predictive
gradient descent is that while your
objective uh hasn't decreased enough you
compute the gradient and the gradients
can be solved and closed from
for uh estimation and prediction for
many of the other optimality criteria
also they can be actually solved in
closed form except for two where you
need to use subgradients
but um that can be done
and then you just take a step you
change your pi from the uniform
initialization you move a small step
size
according to the gradient right that you
have computed here and the step size we
choose by backtracking line search
so we just choose what is the right step
size to use beta s by searching for the
smallest s
using backtracking
and one i guess yeah the key thing is
that now you need to also project so you
can't just move along that
um
just do the gradient update you have to
ensure that your solution still lies in
the feasible set so we actually project
onto that feasible set which is this
uh l1 constraint
right in fact um for the without
replacement setting it's actually an
intersection of l one and l infinity
because remember there we also had upper
bound on pi i each pi i can't be too
large which is an l infinity constraint
so we had to look at how we can project
onto the intersection of an l one and l
infinity ball and we came up with a fast
way to do that essentially reducing it
to a binary search of an auxiliary
parameter yes this problem is
classical
okay
for doing this intersection of this
particular sub problem
uh by some you mean this particular one
okay i see
maybe you can provide me some pointers
optimization i think okay so yeah
but it's naturally because it comes up
okay yeah i'm happy to take more
pointers from you on that
okay
cool so yeah i'm not claiming that as a
big contribution it's just a thing we
ran across and came up with something
but yeah i'm not not at all claiming
that this is the main contribution we
have
right okay um so um yeah what about the
computational complexity what can we say
so what we can say is that the gradient
computation is linear right as you're
pointing out right uh is linear in n the
projection step is also linear in that
right so both these steps are nice how
many iterations does the algorithm take
we have some results for it which i can
show but it's not really great so that's
what i'm saying i think you can probably
come up with either a better analysis of
projected gradient descent
or a better
a different algorithm
that can converge faster but in practice
it takes very very few iterations
so
each step is linear and the total number
of iterations theory we have some result
but practice we see that it converges in
less than 100 iteration to get a
precision of 10 to the minus 5 on very
ill condition matrices and this can be
for as large
uh data sets as 10 000 points it
converges really fast
so at least uh yeah you can implement it
very nicely
so um yeah again if you have thoughts on
this i'll be happy to discuss offline
but let me show some results with
simulation results we tried out with
this algorithm so what i'll be doing is
generating first assimilated results
generating y according to the linear
model with gaussian noise n is thousand
here and p is 50 so that's the
dimensions of the x matrix
and uh we'll be comparing uniform
sampling right so just uniformly
sampling the rows leverage score
sampling that i had mentioned predictor
length sampling which is just sample
proportional to the norm of each row
another natural thing to try
and then our convict solution without
replacement and the hard budget you can
do comparisons with other things it's uh
the same kind of result holes and then
the convex solution followed by the
greedy removal i mentioned
and a federal exchange is actually a
very practical
algorithm that lots of people use it's
built into matlab
and it doesn't have any guarantees on
conversions or on its approximation
capabilities
but it just really exchange exchanges
rows it starts with some subset of size
k and then it exchanges one of them
swaps it with another one if it improves
the objective and just proceeds in this
manner so it's it's just one of those
things that's built in so we thought we
should compare against that turns out it
actually performs pretty well but it's
very slow to converge
okay
so
it starts with the k and then swaps in
and out or yes
starts with k just some random k and
then swaps
picks a pair exchanges it and keeps
doing that so if you would start it with
your immediately generated k with heart
constraint and throw it on to federal
does it make any progress
uh we did not try that yeah
that's a good point we didn't try it so
you have a noise model you assume yes
and the x is arbitrary
x is coming from a specific distribution
it's iid but i'll mention what the
distributions are
okay
so first simulation results and then
i'll also show some real results and for
the random algorithms here just to we
have to do a fair comparison we did run
them a few times and report the median
okay so here's what the results look
like so this is what you're seeing here
is actually the msc of the experimental
design that's chosen relative to msc of
ols and the only reason i'm doing this
is because
it removes the variance aspect right
because otherwise you scale sigma square
you can change this axis to be whatever
right so just to show that and you see
that uniform which is red leverage score
and uh the predicted length sampling are
all doing similar but pretty worse uh so
this is for example from a gaussian
design with a certain decay of the
spectrum of the covariance and
the sampling one we propose the greedy
one and the sweater of exchange actually
do much better
right and in fact the improvement is
larger the more skewed you make the more
ill condition you make the design so if
you sample in from a gaussian from a t
distribution you get larger improvement
and this is expected
okay but uh again i should mention that
this federal exchange it's quite
competitive but it's extremely slow so
i'll show you some runtime next
um so here's a runtime comparison of
pedro with our greedy version actually
the sampling version does pretty similar
to greedy
uh so here we have both the run times
listed and the number of iterations so
you can see in runtimes there's like a
order of at least two
magnitude uh difference between gradient
fedra for all the settings i have for
two different distributions
different k
regimes of sampling
and the number of both the number of
iterations and
yeah runtime both are actually hugely
different
and let me show you some results for the
real data experiments so this is one of
the material census problems i talked
about so regia is one of my
collaborators who
she has this nice way of
trying to use microwaves to synthesize
titanium oxide at much lower
temperatures
and the benefit of that is now you can
put titanium oxide on flexible
substrates you can put them on uh
plastics um for you know anything that's
flexible clothes and so on and uh what
is titanium oxide used for for solar
cells so now you can imagine building
solar cells on flexible things so that's
why it's uh sort of an interesting
direction and what they did was uh but i
mean she has just demonstrated proof of
concept and she wanted to optimize her
input settings to be able to give the
best uh you know coverage of her
whatever you know substrate she's trying
to synthesize this over
and so we tried to help her with um
doing a better material coverage for her
experimental settings and actually she
had an earlier paper trying to look at
uh varying the temperature whole time
ram time these are just some parameters
of our problem and uh showed that a
linear model linear i mean including
some of course quadratic
uh factors but it is a linear model for
our purposes right this she showed that
this does a decent
job at predicting the coverage of this
material
and so she gave her this data set which
had 133 experiments 133 settings for the
temperature hold time round power and so
on and so it has these nine features if
you include the squared ones
and we tried to see uh
given all the budget she had spent every
experiment is like really expensive her
student has to like uh do it very
carefully and then measure the coverage
it's um both the cost of the experiment
and the time consumed is significant
they can only do about one or two
experiments a day
and so instead of 133 experiments if we
had used an experimental design on these
settings so she just gave us the
settings without the corresponding
observations we try to predict those and
see how well we can do and this is how
the different algorithms compare so if
you so think of one as if you had access
to all the 100 you did all the 133
experiments you will be down to one
and you can get to within 1.5 using only
20 to 30 experiments out of the 130 that
she did
so you can get pretty close to
predicting the material coverage with
very few experiments
and this is actually uh this is again
the sampling and greedy which are our
algorithms the federal one it's a little
bit unstable
but you see federer's down here and also
actually leverage score does fairly well
for this specific data set
but we also looked at what are the
experiments that are selected and if you
compare i know this is just a big list
but if you compare leverage score versus
the greedy one then you see that greedy
tends to choose a little bit more
diverse settings for example you see a
lot of temperature settings of 120 here
120 only appears once but you don't see
it appearing much similarly for whole
time there are lots of like zero
settings and also extreme settings like
60 that show up here uh not as much
so it's just i guess a qualitative
comparison to say that it's picking more
diverse set of experiments
here's another data set we looked at
which was wind speed prediction uh where
the goal was to predict the wind speed
at different uh intersections this is a
minnesota
road graph
and
i won't go into all the details but
basically there are 200 sorry 2642
locations we could potentially collect
the measurements for
and
we use some 50 road graph features which
are basically extracted from this road
graph it's these are basically the eigen
eigen vectors of the graph laplacian
essentially and uh they are able to
compress these observations pretty well
so that's why we use those because then
you can think of it as a linear model
and uh here we again compare
uh the prediction error of the
experimental design relative to the ols
solution and you see that fedrov and the
greedy version we propose
they again do the best
and uh what we see here is that leverage
score in this case is worse and so is
actually sampling
but sampling if you increase the k over
p ratio the budget sampling actually
does improve over leveraged score but as
theory predicts that it actually
requires slightly larger requirement on
k k for it needs to scale like p log b
over epsilon square so it requires a
slightly larger budget but then it is
able to do
uh better
and fed ropes again it's competitive but
it's very at least 10 times lower than
the greedy one
okay so yes so
i have a philosophical point since these
experiments are so expensive to do right
why do you care about the running time
the running time is probably a really
tiny fraction of the time it takes to
run all these experiments right i mean
uh yes and no right i mean it depends on
the particular application at hand
you're right yeah maybe in the material
synthesis one yes yeah
or yeah when speedy you probably might
do a second sure sure
i guess yeah i'm i've uh i i'm not tied
to a particular application so i guess i
was trying to come up with like you know
something that works spell for all the
settings
that seems like the most important
measure for these things is not how no
no but let me actually say this even for
i mean sure you're saying we shouldn't
worry but you do still have to go away
from the combinatorial solutions the
combinatorial solutions for these
problems are still not possible even in
a day
yes yeah but yeah whether you do n
versus n square in terms of runtime
slower it doesn't matter yeah in that
case it would not but again that's
completely application dependent there
are applications where you do have to
worry about
when do you get the results as well
and combinatorial is even for very small
problems right you have 100 uh settings
you want to choose you know 10 or 20 out
of those it's still infeasible yeah of
course but i guess what i'm saying is i
get your point yes absolutely
i mean the federal looks pretty dang
good if you could combine that somehow
with yours to get better results that'd
be really interesting right
sure
but it's just yeah i mean it's it's much
much slower so depending on the
application you may or may not want to
use it yes right now it neither has
theory yeah
exactly
right yeah that's the thing it doesn't
have any guarantees and
for either statistical approximation or
for convergence but it's
yes
yes yeah sure
agree
yeah if you can come up with a theory
for it that will be great it doesn't
screw it up
exactly so that's everything empty
already
and then it is a local search which
improves on that exactly that's a great
idea to try that it works out you start
from that right you're saying yes yeah
yeah
that's a good point
okay so i think i only have five minutes
so uh maybe i'll skip the regret
minimization approach uh or so i guess i
i can either talk about like future work
or like feature directions or this
unless people have a opinion one way or
the other
you will okay oh all right okay
sure okay then i'll go over it it's not
too many slides
yes of course yeah it'll be great to get
their feedback so yeah let's let's go
with it all right so how do we post uh
let me tell you more some more details
on the regular minimization we basically
and actually this is not us like this is
really i think those two papers i had
mentioned i'll mention those again here
but basically if you remember in our my
high level proof idea the thing was to
argue that this matrix sub sample matrix
and this condition matrix which contains
the solution of our convex program that
they have
we views that you can get a spectral
specification right the these are both
spectrally similar but i also told you
that all we need is really um the
smallest eigenvalue if we can show that
that's preserved then we are good enough
right so we really care about as long as
you can show this you have a one plus
epsilon approximation
okay uh so to simplify things let's do
one thing let's whitenet our x's
so basically i'm making this side just
identity by doing that
all right and then notice that my
problem here essentially becomes that
now i can look at the white and thing
here
and i essentially want to maximize its
smallest eigenvalue right so getting the
smallest possible epsilon is equal to
maximizing the smallest eigenvalue of
this whiten thing
right
okay so that's our objective maximize
the smallest eigenvalue
and let's call this f of t
okay to pose it into a regret
minimization framework
and then notice that the smallest
eigenvalue is i can just write it like
this
i can write it as the inner product of
this f t with u where we are searching
over u that's
positive semi definite and its trace is
one
all right
so the regret minimization this is going
to be our objective
and the regret is defined as follows and
again these ideas are really coming from
these two papers that did this for uh
graph specification
where you say that we are going to a is
our action space
okay and at any time t
right we are going to uh play this
action and this is the regret
uh or this is our loss we incur and then
this would be you subtract off this
thing and that's your regret right so
this is our goal we want to find an a
that gets us as close to this as
possible right so this is just trying to
find the minimum eigenvalue
so once you post it as a minimum
minimizing the regret problem then there
are solutions that you can use for
example follow the regularized leader is
one of the solutions which is also
related to mirror descent where we every
time we play an action which is of
course in the space
of psd matrices with trace one and it
minimizes its regularized objective
so the regularization this
regularization was also proposed in this
paper
we've just taken it from that and turns
out that this specific uh regularized
loss minimization has a closed form
solution here the c
so alpha is actually a parameter of the
solution but c is just uh you this is
just a constant that ensures that the
solution is actually feasible
all right so it's a small search to try
to get what the c is
and uh if you just post it in minimizing
the regret again a is just here trying
to get to you
right that's the objective so it doesn't
directly tell you what to sub sample
but the regret once we do write it as a
record minimization and we analyze the
regret the analysis indicates how you
should be picking the eyes
the sub samples
okay so that's what we did and so the
now the regret minimization solution is
you of course give it this contractual
acceleration
uh the solution of that
and i said alpha is the other algorithm
parameter that's there so the first step
is just whitening and then
uh we do it for k iterations so at every
iteration we are going to choose an
action and we are going to sub sample a
row and proceed like that and so ct is
ah this is a small subroutine i didn't
present but it just ensures that your
current solution is feasible
all right just checks for that or finds
a setting for which it is feasible and
then this is the closed form solution i
just mentioned of that regret
minimization problem
and depending on if you're doing with
replacement you don't throw anything out
your
the candidate set of rows you can choose
from is one to n but if it's without
replacement then you throw off what
you've already chosen and then you just
simply pick the
row that gives you maximum value of this
quantity and this is coming from the
regret analysis
the specific choice of which
row to keep
and you proceed in this fashion for k
iterations and then you're done yes so
the find constant is like solved
finding procedure
it's uh yeah you just basically you can
do binary bisection over what you expect
the largest eigen value to be and the
smallest and you ensure that your
solution you keep having it every time
until you're
you meet the constraints that it's
positive semi-definite and yeah so in
that sense yes
right so so this is yeah what the um
approaches
and uh
i already showed you the results so yeah
it's able to get this one plus epsilon
approximation with the budget that's
scaling linearly with b
because that's improvement over this p
square and including the hard budget
setting
okay
and uh another thing as i said like here
we are able to actually extend the
analysis to handle any of these criteria
and broadly speaking actually
so well that's my thing again about it's
still open how to get p over epsilon but
broadly speaking it actually works for
so here are all the different criteria
oh actually here it is you are looking
for what a optimality is it's average
optimality
um and then you have the determinant
which stands for d and so on yeah but it
works for basically any criteria which
satisfies these we call it regular
criteria these three properties
that it's convex in its argument
it's monotone
that if a dominant speed then f of a is
bigger than f of b and reciprocal
monotonicity so if i multiply my uh yeah
the
covalence matrix with uh t then you get
t inverse of f of a and all of these
criteria satisfy these that's why it's
applicable to any of those
and yeah in terms of results i guess
again
the
observation is similar that so here this
is uniform sampling this is our sampling
from the previous
approach federal's exchange and then
this is the regret minimization one it
does actually here it is beating
redraws but
yeah overall
actually even here it's reading it quite
a lot but slightly worse on this one so
it does the best overall and again
there's a huge difference in runtime
and this is a true for different
settings of okay
the budget
and sampling which i had shown earlier
is i mean in some sense these three are
comparable
i mean some improvements in some cases
but they are comparable but uh sampling
is a little bit sometimes when you see
the n f it actually fails to return a
positive semi different solution so
that's why we've returned it as if
in these problems
but it has similar runtime and
overall the guarantees are similar
and this is on that
wind speed data set again
same kind of result that it
this is the regret minimization
algorithm however it does
and this is
the federal exchange and weighted
sampling and so on and it does
as well as the best possible if not
better and has a very small runtime
and that's just what the full sample
solution would have looked like just for
comparison
okay so with that let me mention some
extensions so one thing we thought a
little bit about was whether we can
extend it to the journalized linear
model where our y instead of mean x beta
plus epsilon is g of x beta plus epsilon
okay and it turns out in this case if
you look at your maximum likelihood
solution then it depends on the fissure
information
uh which depends on the true regression
coefficient speed or not unlike the
standard linear model so uh first so
it's not a two one step process then you
have to do a two step process you first
have to use some samples to estimate get
a crude estimate of it or not and we
show a screwed estimated sufficient just
a consistent estimate of whether or not
in the first step and then there is a
way you can transform your points so the
original points were x i you can
transform them so that you are still
back to this objective we discussed
earlier and we can say specifically what
this transformation is for example for
logistic regression it's
this for a poisson count model it is
like that like this it has a simple
closed form solution for many of these
problems
um overall high level uh future
directions are one as i said uh getting
this better
uh one plus epsilon approximation with
sampling budget scaling like b over
epsilon faster converging algorithms if
you care about that um
and here's another one that we we
haven't thought of this too much but
it's interesting because i think it
actually is much harder so you can think
of the current approach as saying either
i want to keep a row or not keep a row
right so basically keeper o means you'll
observe the corresponding y or not
observe it but once you observe the y
the y is observed with full accuracy in
some sense
but what if i have a bit budget
constraint so if i can say that there is
a budget on how accurately you can
measure wise
so one way you can have this budget is
in terms of a bit right you have certain
number of bits that you need to allocate
to measuring the different y's maybe
these are sensors quantizing your
measurements it comes up in brain
computer interface problems where you
need to quantize again and so now the
constraint is instead of you know a sum
over w i the weight of each
row the constraint is in terms of the
weight can be written as 2 to the bi and
the constraint is on the ba
turns out this is actually a non-convex
problem
so how to solve it is i think is also an
interesting open question
and the last one is extensions to high
dimensional setting
so we only considered the case where our
x was a tall matrix right so we have
lots of parameter settings but few
features
uh you can consider the other setting
where you have lots of features
describing different patients and so on
and you need to i mean
n is smaller than p but you still it's
still large that you need to choose a
subset of it to do a feasible inference
and it turned out that this problem was
actually uh actually initially when we
started out this was one of the
motivating papers so in a paper by mark
davenport uh georgia tech uh yeah ms
amino needle and wolf they considered
the setting that you have um they were
they come from the compressed sensing
community and they were talking about
that you have an mri image which is
actually sparse in the wavelet basis
but all mri images are actually acquired
in the frequency domain
so what you have a model there is that
this is your frequency
right the fourier matrix this is the
wavelet matrix and what you're observing
is like a product of these so you are
really the beta vector which is high
dimensional and sparse is over here
and they were saying um and sometimes
people say well you can just instead of
observing in the fourier domain you
should do random projections which is
hard you have to change all the hardware
and so on so the problem they were
considering is can we choose a subset of
the frequencies to observe
then which are the frequencies we should
observe to still be able to recover the
beta which is now this high dimensional
problem so it's a subset selection but
in the high dimensional setting and the
convex taxation we proposed again i
think i've seen it in at least this
paper but like i think there is a other
paper also so viewer i think we did the
analysis so no analysis was done here
but they actually proposed an approach
which had that convex solution they said
that we just split the budget in half
and you use half the budget to estimate
the
support of beta and then you are down to
a lower dimensional problem and then you
basically have this still a hard problem
of doing this convex
but there you can use this convex
solution
so that's it uh here are some pointers
to related papers and these are all the
students who've contributed to this
project
and uh thank you
[Applause]
questions
so um so i think you've done a lot of
work on looking at cases where the level
of noise fluctuates um it's not just a
standard sigma squared
yeah the heteroskedastic case um
i don't know if like maybe there is work
i don't know of work that has addressed
that it seems like that would be a
pretty hard
problem as well right because you then
you have to estimate because it then it
depends whether you know the hetero
elasticity like right um the noise
variance function or you don't know it
and yeah that brings a lot of challenges
but it's a good one
you can probably do so i guess it
depends on uh if your function is still
linear and your noise variance changes
but it's you know
changes in some complicated way uh
then maybe there is still a way to
learn it because i think it has been
shown that there are the estimating the
covariance part is like a second order
effect so you don't need as many samples
to sort of
get rid of it so that something might be
possible but again i haven't thought of
it
okay it seems like leveraged course
if you want to approximately linear
regression factor 1 plus epsilon
it requires a new notation p log b p
plus p over epsilon
so
so it is very close to the p over
epsilon already
but it's again as i said like there the
goal is computational you care about
approximating the full ols solution
not picking the best subset according to
a stochastic model
so these two objectives are slightly
different
but you're right yeah that's why
actually we did compare against
celebrate score and i think that was a
strong uh first thing that came to our
mind as well because
it can get you a good approximation for
the full oil escalation
like i guess one key thing there is that
you have to re-weight your points after
sampling
right and in a stochastic model if you
do that you're sort of boosting your
noise as well so it doesn't work out the
same way if you care about finding the
best subset that can learn the beta
vector the regression coefficients in a
stochastic model
[Applause]